in an era where Hollywood is adapting
what seems like every property they can
get their hands on why has there never
been a Grand Theft Auto movie at one
point fans almost got a GTA movie
starring an international rap Superstar
there have been many video game flicks
some better than others and while a
solid number of titles have been
successful at the box office translating
the console fun into an entertaining
cinematic Endeavor has always been
widely considered to be a tricky
business
47 it's not a name
no but it is mine
okay just because a franchise does well
with Gamers or offers a Next Level
gameplay experience attracting millions
of users doesn't mean things are
guaranteed to always work out at the box
office but some would argue that a Grand
Theft Auto feature is a no-brainer
everything the franchise has to offer
could arguably be turned into a
thrilling action-packed crime drama
anyone who has played any of the
iterations released over the years knows
there is plenty of wild Mayhem and
Stellar stories that could make for a
worthwhile movie night it's not like
Rockstar Games hasn't gotten offers to
bring their property to the big screen
there was even even a moment when a
controversial grammy-winning artist was
pitched as the star of a grand theft
Automotion picture according to Kurt euu
a seasoned player in the gaming industry
shortly after Grand Theft Auto 3 came
out he spoke with GTA co-creator Sam
Hower about a possible film adaptation
and then an alluring offer came into
play youing said on the BBC podcast
Bugsy Malone's grandest game and
remember taking a call at about 4:00
a.m. from one of the producers in LA
with an offer to make a film and he said
KT we've got Eminem to Star and it's a
Tony Scott film 5 million on the nose
are you interested but when he told
Hower about it he was shocked when the
GTA head honcho said he was not
interested after that the idea of the
game making the jump to the big screen
disappeared for those that don't
remember GTA 3 came out in 2001 at the
time Eminem was writing the success of
the Marshall matters LP and was getting
into the acting game with a starring
role in the critically acclaimed feature
Mile my techniques bizarre and I Scar
and kill you were a star until I sered
you like a bar and grill Top Gun
director Tony Scott released films like
enemy of the state and Spy game in that
era adding to the many reasons the two
were presumably chosen but it appears
they weren't what was bothering Hower it
was the money in an interview with
Empire he revealed why GTA hadn't
received the movie treatment saying
we've been offered many times and it's
never appealed the money's never been
close to be worth risking one's crown
jewels the days when an Eminem starring
Grand Theft Auto movie Could Happen
seemed long gone however the
overwhelmingly positive response to the
elite GTA 6 trailer along with video
game adaptations being more popular than
ever thanks to successes like the last
of us in the Super Mario Brothers movie
may make fans think a GTA film could
still be on the table but it'd be best
not to hold your breath Strauss zelnick
the CEO of take two interactive spoke
with the rap in 2019 about the
possibility of a GTA movie at some point
saying part of it is if we were to do
something like that we'd want to have
complete creative control to make sure
we expressed GTA in the way we wanted
and that would mean we'd need to finance
that motion picture he then got into the
Catch 22 of the issue he and others who
work at Take 2 aren't super familiar
with the film industry so he doubts they
could adequately adapt the franchise
into a movie simply put he just doesn't
trust anyone else to do GTA Justice
zelnick added you have the most valuable
intellectual property ever created by
mankind Grand Theft Auto we wholly own
and control it are we really going to
let go of that and hope that someone no
matter how talented they are will do a
really good job with
[Music]
it